a drawdown or a deception
russia says some of its forces are
pulling back from ukraine's borders
having finished their exercises
nato allies aren't convinced
we do not see any sign of de-escalation
on the ground
no withdrawals of troops or equipment
this may of course change
however what we see today
is that russia maintains a massive
invasion force ready to attack
defence ministers meeting in brussels
agreed to draw up plans for more combat
units on the alliance's eastern flank
that won't be welcomed by russia which
denies any plan to attack ukraine and
defends its right to conduct drills
within its borders
all those troops
are in russian territory
with the only exception of those
participating in joint exercises with
belarus in the territory of that country
and that exercise uh
is it in its finishing stage for ukraine
it means instability and uncertainty
continue
this bank one of the targets this week
of what ukrainian officials say is the
biggest denial of service cyber attack
in the country's history
cyber hacks ahead of a military
offensive something russia's done before
whether or not an invasion happens
president putin has already succeeded in
creating a security crisis in europe
paralyzing ukraine and consuming the
attention of western leaders for weeks
in fact many believe that the threat of
war backed by a highly capable military
is now the main foreign policy tool of
the kremlin
the western city of lev is home to new
visitors after the acting u.s ambassador
to ukraine and her staff moved there
from kiev because of the military threat
in fact washington had named today as
when a russian offensive might start
and it's still worried
no one will know the exact date but
president putin himself but
we are concerned we're very concerned
that it could be soon perhaps within the
next week
but as ukraine marks what its president
has called a day of unity
opinions still very much divided over
whether a russian attack will happen or
not debrahing sky news kiev
you